Hi zusammen! Heute machen wir leckere Ćevapčići.
Das sind Hackfleisch...
[Hamza] Gegrillte Hackfleisch..
[Kiki] Gegrillte Hackfleisch-....stangen?
*beide lachen*
Also Ćevapčići kennt eigentlich jeder! Ich muss gar nicht beschreiben, was das ist.
Ihr könnt das nach diesem Rezept grillen oder so wie ich heute in der Pfanne anbraten.
Ich weiß es gibt das Traditionsrezept aus dem Balkan.
Ich glaube ursprünglich wird's dann auch mit Schwein und Lamm gemischt gemacht.
[Hamza] Kommt auch ursprünglich aus Bosnien, oder?
Ursprünglich aus Bosnien aber auch in der kroatischen Küche mega beliebt, also generell im ganzen Balkan.
Und heute mach ich das eben auf Kiki Art: Ich nehme heute Rindergehacktes,
ich nehme Zutaten, die ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon alle so Zuhause habt
und zeige euch eine ganz einfache Zubereitung.
Und dafür fange ich jetzt direkt an. Läuft die Kamera?
Super!
Ich nehm mir jetzt meinen Gemüsehobel und reibe da Zwiebeln rein.
Also schön fein, am besten diese feine Seite benutzen.
Wenn ihr's grob macht, dann hat das für mich nicht so ein leckeres Mundgefühl.
Im Anschluss geben wir die Knoblauchzehen dazu und ich press sie jetzt einfach durch die Knoblauchpresse.
Ihr könntet sie auch fein hacken.
Dann kommen natürlich noch Salz und Pfeffer dazu
und ich möchte auf Petersilie jetzt auch nicht verzichten!
Dadurch, dass ich es sehr fein möchte, nehme ich hier mein Wiegemesser
und gebe das jetzt auch noch mit dazu wobei die Petersilie echt optional ist.
Aber probiert's mal aus, die gibt echt noch mal einen richtig leckeren Geschmack!
So und jetzt kommen noch 3 wichtige Zutaten und zwar:
Einmal hier rüber: Unser Backpulver, das ist super, super wichtig!
Das gebe ich direkt schon mit dazu und unsere 2 Gewürze.
Ich nehme hier Paprika edelsüß und Pul Biber.
Ich weiß das ist jetzt ein türkisches Wort aber das sind Paprikaflocken und die sind ein bisschen schärfer
und ich mag's halt gern wenn's nicht so scharf ist.
Deswegen nehme ich auf jeden Fall noch Paprika edelsüß mit dazu.
[Hamza] *gestellt* Sag mal, sind das neue Gewürze?
[Kiki] Jaaa!
[Hamza] *gestellt* Boah, mega!
[Kiki] Find ich auch!
[Hamza] So, das war ich wieder mit meiner Werbestimme!
[Kiki] Da war der Hamza mit seiner Werbestimme.
Also ich verlinke euch nicht nur die Gewürze und auch meine Utensilien aus dem Shop in die Infobox,
sondern auch die ganz genauen Mengenangaben falls ihr euch wundert, wo sie denn stehen.
Und jetzt geht's los: Jetzt nehm ich mir die sauberen Finger und knete das richtig lange durch
sodass die Masse auch sich ineinander so ein bisschen verbindet.
Also ihr werdet's merken. Ich kann's nicht so gut beschreiben
aber je länger ihr knetet, desto besser könnt ihr sie später dann auch formen.
[Hamza] Das könnte man theoretisch auch mit der Küchenmaschine jetzt machen, oder?
Genau, das könnte man auch mit 'ner Küchenmaschine machen, das hast du richtig erkannt.
[Hamza] Knethaken, richtig?
[Kiki] Ich würde tatsächlich den Rührhaken nehmen.
[Hamza] Ah mein ich ja!
Ich hab jetzt genau 5min mit meinen Händen geknetet
und man merkt, dass die Konsistenz echt anders wird.
Also es verbindet sich einfach alles miteinander.
Und wenn ihr lange genug knetet, braucht ihr auch weder Ei, noch Paniermehl.
Und jetzt deckt ihr das ab. Entweder nehmt ihr euch Frischhaltefolie
oder irgendeinen Gegenstand, so mach ich das.
Und jetzt sollte das für 1h in den Kühlschrank.
Wenn ihr mehr Zeit habt, 2,3,4h, ist vollkommen egal.
Hauptsache die Gewürze ziehen richtig schön ein, Knoblauch und Zwiebeln entfalten sich
und dann geht's weiter. Aber ich mache in der Zwischenzeit schon mal Tzatziki dazu.
[Hamza] Warum gehst du nicht ausm Bild jetzt?
[Kiki] Achso, soll ich ausm Bild gehen?
[Hamza] Du tust es doch in den Kühlschrank hast du gesagt!
[Kiki] Okay, ja. Bis gleich!
[Hamza] *lacht*
Für unser Tzatziki ganz einfach Gurken, frische Minze (ihr könnt auch gern getrocknete nehmen),
Knoblauch und Salz mit zum Joghurt geben und dann kurz verrühren.
Ich hab hier fettarmen Joghurt genommen, 1,5%-igen.
Ihr könntet auch den fettreichen nehmen und mein Tipp falls ihr jetzt z.B. nur den 10%-igen da habt:
Ihr könnt da ein bisschen Mineralwasser reingeben und das Ganze so ein bisschen auflockern.
So, und jetzt geht's schon weiter mit unserem Fleisch.
Und da hab ich mir was richtig Tolles überlegt:
Ich hab's auch grad mal ausprobiert, das funktioniert auch.
Ihr nehmt euch einfach einen Spritzbeutel - natürlich geht das auch ohne, dann formt ihr das ganz einfach mit den Händen.
[Kiki] Aber ich zeig euch mal wie einfach und schnell das geht!
[Hamza] So hat man dann gleichmäßig große Stücke, ne?
Genau, gleichmäßig groß und es ist halt wirklich einfacher und schneller
und dadurch, dass sie auch gleichmäßig sind, werden sie dann gleichzeitig gar gleich im Fett.
Also einfach reingeben und dann nehme ich mir - also ich mach da jetzt auch keine Tülle dran,
ich find das jetzt ein bisschen übetrieben. Das könnte man auch machen..
[Kiki] Aber..
[Hamza] So 'ne Sterntülle! *lacht*
Jaa! Ich nehm mir jetzt einfach ein Messer und schneide vorne die Spitze ab
[Kiki] ..und dann hat man ja automatisch ein Loch.
[Hamza] 'Ne Schere, Kiki!
[Kiki] Was hab ich denn gesagt?
[Hamza] Messer!
[Kiki] Ah, ne Schere, tschuldigung!
Und jetzt bereite ich mir das hier vor auf meinem Brett,
danach erhitze ich mein Fett in der Pfanne
und dann kann das schön gleichmäßig ausgebraten werden.
[Kiki] Dann 'ne Schere nehmen und das hier einfach abmachen.
[Hamza] Schere? Messer!
[Kiki] Aah ein Messer, oh mein Gott!
*beide lachen*
[Kiki] Ja?
[Hamza] Du magst es, verwirrt zu sein, ne?
[Kiki] *lacht* Ja!
[Hamza] So, wir machen jetzt Teamwork!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Kiki] Ich presse und du schneidest!
[Hamza] Genau. Und jetzt dranhalten und dann hoch, ne?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Boah! Leute ich bin krass ey!
[Kiki] Boah!
[Kiki] Der ist perfekt geworden!
[Hamza] Krass, ne?
[Kiki] Boah du filmst und schneidest!
[Hamza] Ich filme und schneide!
[Hamza] Also cutten!
*beide lachen*
[Hamza] Uund.. yes!
So, ich gucke immer zwischendurch ob die schon gar sind.
Ja, perfekt!
Ich rate euch schon dazu, viel Öl zu nehmen.
Also ihr müsst sie nicht komplett da drin frittieren aber es ist schon so fast wie frittieren.
Dann werden sie meiner Meinung nach echt am Besten
und die brauchen so pro Seite ca. 2½min, nicht länger.
Also.. ihr müsst euch vorstellen:
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum ich das so erkläre aber ich glaube dadurch, dass man das ja nicht schmecken kann durch die Kamera, muss ich das erklären.
Die sind außen knackig und innen soft.
[Kiki] Und dann könnt ihr sie mit Gewürzreiz - Gewürzreis essen.
[Hamza] Gewürzreiz!
Oder mit Ajvar, das ist diese typische Paste.
[Hamza] Ist das scharf?
[Kiki] Oder - ja genau, die ist scharf.
Oder einfach hier in Tzatziki tunken und dann rein damit!
Boah!
Richtig lecker! Was auch viele machen: Die nehmen sich dann Brot, z.B. Pitabrot
oder Fladenbrot, irgendwas und tun sich das da rein, auch richtig lecker!
[Hamza] Wie so'n Döner!
[Kiki] Wie so 'ne Art Döner! Boah, das darfst du jetzt nicht sagen, das ist so..
[Kiki] Döner und..
[Hamza] Ja ich weiß!
[Hamza] Reis hast du auch schon dazu gegessen oder?
[Kiki] Genau, man kann auch Reiz - Reiz, was hab ich heute?!
[Hamza] Reiz! Reis servieren.
[Kiki] Reis! Gewürzreis z.B.
Wie ihr möchtet! Also ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachmachen
und schreibt mir unbedingt unten in die Kommentare, was ihr als nächstes sehen möchtet.
Ich hab grad eben noch gezählt, es kommen 56 kleine Ćevapčići raus.
Also die sind dann schon relativ klein.
Wenn ihr sie länger macht, dann vielleicht so 50, 48.
Nur damit ihr da so bescheid wisst.
Ansonsten habt noch einen wunderschönen Tag!
Vergesst nicht diesem Video eine positive Bewertung in Form eines Daumens da zu lassen!
Und dann würde ich mal sagen: Bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!
[Kiki] So, Hamza macht den Taste Test für uns.
[Hamza] Ich mach den Taste Test jetzt für uns!
[Hamza] Ich hab bisschen lauter geredet weil das Mikrofon ist hier.
[Hamza] Ich hab in meinem Leben noch nie Ćevap- Ćevapčići?
[Kiki] Ćevapčići!
[Hamza] Ich verwechsel das immer mit Čuvapci!
[Kiki] Čupavci!
[Hamza] Čupavci, auch lecker!
[Hamza] Ey wofür diese Gabel? Ich mag das nicht. Ich bin Araber, ich ess mit der Hand!
[Hamza] Mmh, mmh! Ich weiß was du meinst mit diesem "außen knusprig und innen weich"!
[Hamza] Das schmeckt heftig! Vor allem ist es einfach lecker gewürzt.
[Hamza] Das ist nicht einfach nur Hackfleisch mit Salz sondern man merkt einfach da ist ein bisschen mehr drin.
[Hamza] Und ich schwöre es dir: Das schmeckt gegrillt!
[Hamza] Es schmeckt gegrillt, ich weiß nicht, wieso!
[Kiki] Echt?
[Hamza] Das schmeckt gegrillt! Ja, keine Ahnung! Vielleicht macht das die Petersilie drin aber es schmeckt irgendwie gegrillt.
[Hamza] So lecker gegrillte - ich sag mal Köfte, so ähnlich.
[Hamza] Obwohl du's in der Pfanne gemacht hast, schmeckt das gegrillt.
[Hamza] Und das ist dieses Ajvar, ne?
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Okay ich hoffe das ist nicht zu scharf weil ich mag kein scharf!
[Hamza] M-hm, m-hm... Du hast mich reingelegt, das ist Tomatenmark!
*beide lachen*
[Kiki] Ich hatte kein Ajvar da. Ich wollte es so imitieren weil das ist halt ein Rezeptvorschlag!
[Kiki] Ich hab dich einfach geprankt!
[Hamza] Aber es schmeckt gut!
[Hamza] Also Leute.. ihr Balkanländer, ihr habt echt leckeres Fleisch!
[Hamza] Kiki!
[Kiki] Das Witzige ist ja.. während des Drehs so locker..
[Hamza] Lass mich auch noch essen!
[Kiki] Ich hab ja locker so 8 Stück oder so während des Drehs gegessen -
[Kiki] Ah ist das schwer! Die Kamera ist so schwer, mein Arm bricht ab!
[Kiki] Auf jeden Fall sieht man so im Hintergrund - zeig mal!
[Kiki] Da liegt schon meine Decke ausm Schlafzimmer, mein Kaffee steht bereit!
[Kiki] Datteln hab ich mir befüllt mit Haselnusscreme und wollte mir so 'nen Filmeabend machen! *lacht*
[Hamza] Aber ich bin noch beim Mittagessen!
[Kiki] Ja, ich bin schon ein bisschen weiter als du heute!
[Hamza] Du musst auf mich warten. Leute ciao!
[Kiki] Tschüss!
[Hamza] Sollten wir sowas öfter machen? Also hier am Wohnzimmertisch probieren?
[Kiki] Das ist -
[Kiki] Oh tschuldigung!
[Hamza] Das ist unser neues Format!
[Kiki] Das ist unser Tasty Table!
[Hamza] Tasty Table!
[Kiki] Okay Tasty Table jetzt immer hier, wir sehen uns! Tschüss!
[Hamza] Ciao!
[Hamza] Peew! Wie macht man das aus hier?